IS IT JUST A HE SAID-SHE SAID?
IS IT REALLY THAT SIMPLE?
AND WHY IS THIS NOW IN THE HANDS
OF THE FBI?
WHY?
BECAUSE THE ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS ARE BUCKLED, CAUSED
AND BOWED TO THE DEMOCRATS OR
SHOULD I SAY DEMON RATS.
THE SPECTACLE I SAW THIS WEEK
WAS ONE OF THE MOST OF PATHETIC,
DISHEARTENING, SADDEST DISPLAYS
TO WHICH THIS NATION HAS EVER
STOOD WITNESS.
IT WAS FOR ALL INTENTS AND
PURPOSES A CRUCIFIXION OF A MAN
WHO LED THE KIND OF EXEMPLARY
LIFE KNEW OF US CAN MIRROR.
I WAS A FELONY COURT JUDGE.
I WAS A PROSECUTOR AND D.A.
SEX CRIMES AGAINST WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WERE MY CRUSADE.
I ASSESSED WHETHER CASES SHOULD
GO FORWARD, IF THE ACCUSED
SHOULD BE CONVICTED AND AS A
JUDGE WHAT THE SENTENCE SHOULD
BE.
NO ONE SYMPATHIZES MORE THAN I
WHEN IT COMES TO WOMEN WHO ARE
THE SILENT VICTIMS OF CRIMES.
I CREATED THE FIRST DOMESTIC
CHRIS TEEN  *
NARIS TEEN  *
NATIS TEEN  *
NATIONTEEN  *
VIOLENCE SECTION IN THE NATION.
NATION.EEN  *
-- CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD IS A
LOVEY LADY AND I BELIEVE
SOMETHING HAPPENED TO HER.
BUT SHE IS IN OVER HER HEAD AND
SHE IS BEING USED.
NO MATTER HOW MANY HIPPOCAMPUS
BRAIN COMPARISONS SHE MADE.
SHE COULDN'T REMEMBER THE
FUNDAMENTALS, WHOSE HOUSE IT
WAS, WHERE IT WAS, HOW SHE GOT
TO THE HOUSE OR HOW SHE GOT
HOME.
SHE WENT 36 YEARS WITHOUT
TELLING ANYONE BEFORE NOW.
IF FORD SAID NO ONE WAS THERE,
THAT IT WAS JUST SHE AND
KAVANAUGH AND JUST HE AND SHE
ALONE IN THE PARKING LOT, THEN
IT'S A TRUE HE SAID-SHE SAID.
BUT ONCE SHE CHOSE TO SAY THERE
WERE FOUR PEOPLE THERE IT'S A
THEY SAID.
YET ALL FOUR OF THEY SAID
SOMETHING HAPPENED.
THEY WEREN'T THERE.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE IS
TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
FORD'S MEMORY?
IF THEY WEREN'T THERE, IS IT
POSSIBLE KAVANAUGH WASN'T THERE
EITHER?
CRUCIAL HERE IS FORD'S THERAPY
VISIT IN 2012.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THREE
DECADE SHE SAYS SHE MENTIONED
KAVANAUGH'S NAME.
IF TRUE, WHY WAS THE NAME
KAVANAUGH NOT IN THE THERAPIST
NOTES.
AND WHY WOULD FORD'S LAWYERS
WITH HOLD THOSE THERAPIST NOTES,
AT LEAST THE PART THAT REFERRED
TO THIS ALLEGED EVENT.
WHY WAS FORD SO EVASIVE WHEN
QUESTIONED BY THE PROSECUTOR ON
THIS ISSUE.
WHY DID HER ATTORNEY INTERFERE
WITH HER ANSWERING IN HER
TESTIMONY ON THIS POINT.
THE MESSAGE USED TO HELP HER
RECALL WHATEVER TRAUMATIC EVENT
OCCURRED.
IF A RAPE VICTIM UNDERGOES
HYPNOSIS THE COURT AND JURY IS
ENTITLED TO KNOW.
BECAUSE OF THE RISK LIKE
TELEVISION, NEWSPAPERS, THAT
IMPACT ONE'S MEMORY, IT IS NOT A
RELIABLE MEANS REFRESHING ONE'S
RECOLLECTION.
HER ATTORNEYS SAID SHE WAS
AFRAID TO FLY AND HAD TO DRIVE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BUT SHE WAS NEVER TOLD THE
COMMITTEE WAS WILLING TO COME TO
HER.
SHE IS NOT AFRAID TO FLY.
SHE HAS FLOWN ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, THE WORLD, THE SOUTH
PACIFIC AND HAWAII.
MOVE ALL OF THAT OUT OF THE WAY.
WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH HERE IS
HYPOCRISY.
NOT WHAT'S RIGHT AND WRONG,
WHO'S GUILTY AND INNOCENT.
THIS IS ABOUT PEOPLE DESPERATE
TO WIN AT ALL COSTS.
TAKE A MAN AND HIS FAMILY DOWN,
NO PROBLEM.
IT'S THE BATTLE OF THE
HYPOCRITES.
JEFF FLAKE IS THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE.
HE SAYS AFTER THE HEARING HE'S
GOING TO VOTE FOR KAVANAUGH.
BUT THE MAN BUCKLES AFTER TWO
WOMEN SCREAM AT HIM WHILE
PREVENTING HIS ELEVATOR DOOR
FROM CLOSING.
>> LOOK AT ME WHEN I'M TALKING
TO YOU.
YOU ARE TELLING  ME MY VOTE
DOESN'T MATTER.
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME DOESN'T
MATTER.
JUDGE JEANINE: OF COURSE IT
MATTERS.
BUT WHAT DOES YOUR ABUSE HAVE TO
DO WITH BRETT KAVANAUGH?
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF WOMEN
HAVE BEEN ABUSED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
TAKE YOUR ANGER OUT ON THE
PERSON WHO ABUSED YOU.
GO TO COURT, CONVICT HIM, SEND
HIM TO JAIL, SPIT ON HIM, I
DON'T CARE.
BUT DON'T YOU DARE BLAME BRETT
KAVANAUGH FOR YOUR
VICTIMIZATION.
ONLY WHEN JEFF FLAKE IS DUMB
ENOUGH, WEAK ENOUGH TO NOT EVEN
GET.
SPARTACUS HAS THE GAL TO
SPARTACUS HAS THE -AL TO
SPARTACUS HAS THE --L TO
SPARTACUS HAS THE -- TTO
CORY BOOKER THE WANNABE
SPARTACUS HAS THE -- THE GALL TO
STAND UP AND CRITICIZE.
BERKE ADMITS GROPING ANOTHER
YOUNG WOMAN WHEN HE WAS 15.
WHY AREN'T WE GOING AFTER HIM.
AND GNATS GENIUS -- THAT GENIUS
SENATOR MAIZIE HIRONO WHO
ALLEGEDLY GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL.
SKIPPED THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE CLASS.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE NERVE TO SAY
THE REPUBLICANS TOSSED OUT THE
RULES.
YOU ARE THE ONE WHO DECLARED
KAVANAUGH GUILTY BEFORE YOU
HEARD ANY DEFENDANT MONEY
BECAUSE SHE WAS THE ACCUSER AND
ALL MEN SHOULD SHUT UP.
AND YOU ARE SAYING ALL
CONSERVATIVES ARE NOT ENTITLED
TO THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE?
WHO ARE YOU?
BUT MY FAVORITE, DIANNE
FEINSTEIN.
MADAME, YOU DON'T DESERVE TO BE
IN THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
AND NO ONE CAN BELIEVE ANYTHING
YOU HAVE TO SAY.
EACH OF THESE ALLEGATIONS SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATED BY THE FBI.
JUDGE JEANINE: TWO DAYS AGO YOU
CALLED FOR AN FBI INVESTIGATION.
WHAT A SHOCK.
WHY DIDN'T YOU ASK FOR IT IN
JULY WHEN YOU GOT THE FORD
LETTER?
YOU DIDN'T ASK FOR IT BECAUSE
NO, LIKE A CHESS SHIRE
NO, LIKE A CHESSSHHIRE
NO, LIKE A CHESSSHIRRE
NO, LIKE A CHESSSHIREE
AROUND HYPOCRITE.
NO, LIKE A CHESSSHIRE CAT YOU
SAT ON IT.
CHRISTINE FORD DIDN'T WANT TO
BE EXPOSED.
BUT, NO, YOU HAD OTHER PLANS.
YOUR PLAN WAS TO LIKE THE.
YOU ACTUALLY GAVE FORD THE NAME
OF THE DREM KRAT ATTORNEY.
BOOR DR. FORD, THERE IS WOMAN
DOESN'T KNOW SHE WAS NOTHING
MORE THAN A PUPPET ON THE STRING
OF DEMOCRATIC POLITICS.
DIANNE, WHERE IS YOUR INTEGRITY.
YOU AND EVERYONE IN THE SENATE
KNOW HOW THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
HAND.
CONFIDENTIALLY.
THE FBI SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED.
NO ONE HAS RESPECT FOR YOU.
IN THE END LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID
IT BEST.
>> THERE IS NO WAY TO
INVESTIGATE SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED 35 YEARS AGO WHEN YOU
CAN'T TELL THE MONTH, THE
LOCATION.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT GET TOGETHER
TRUTH.
JUDGE JEANINE: THAT'S THE
OPENING STATEMENT.
IF YOU LIKE MY OPENING